without having women around there's a
certain level of understanding that you
can't receive from your guy best friend
women have a different sense of
nurturing that i think is really
important to always have around
hi there i'm tati gabrielle and this is
my glamour unfiltered
i have gotten so much feedback from
women who have seen my characters that
it's strengthened them so i feel like
all the way around it's empowering i
would hope that they would find a piece
of these women in themselves and be
reminded and reassured that they do have
stake in this world that they do have a
voice that that voice needs to be heard
and can be heard i would hope more than
anything that i would teach them to be
unapologetic unapologetically themselves
unapologetically bold
tom holland is the sweetest
he's very silly very goofy very funny
there's a picture that i took of him
that i feel like encapsulates tom very
well
he's hanging from something
while like flipping me off through the
camera
and like and with this very like goofy
face like and it's it's just a very
silly cute photo
yeah i grew up in zendaya um and we went
to school together um for middle school
and early high school tom was texting
her while we were we were filming and
then she text me it was like hey he says
you're doing super awesome i'm like
sending love and i was like oh thanks
man
i've been very grateful to have not been
in
any like sort of sketchy situations i
had like one small moment happen like my
very first year working um that i
quickly squashed myself and built felt
very proud of myself for that and it's
never happened again i'm grateful that
i'm in the generation that i'm in that
times are changing that it's not
something that we have to experience as
much as like
the two previous generations before us
like i can't imagine some of the things
that these women had to go through in
that does really like tear my heart out
sometimes when i as i hear stories as i
as i
when that when that movement was
happening and sort of realizing the
scope of it it was like oh it was
sickening
i was diagnosed with depression and
generalized anxiety disorder in college
um recently that has upgraded to bipolar
disorder and generalized anxiety
disorder
and adhd i struggled a lot when i was in
school um not having the proper
resources or really guidance at that
time
once i got to la i really started on my
own sort of self-love self-care and
self-therapy
every day i is something i have to
manage or
um take care of but i also welcome while
i have adhd i'm also able to
take in a lot of information all at one
time i might get tired but that's okay i
am able to gather more information than
the average person might
the idea that marianne talks about at
the end of of season three where she's
you know she says that you know i'm
attracted to toxic men and i realize
it's because there's toxicity in me um
and that was something that i was like
yes and i was happy to be able to
deliver that line and hope that other
women who might be in that space like
could hear that and
um
take in that conversation and for for
their own self i have been in an abusive
relationship before
and it was my family
and my loved ones
um
literally had to pull me out sort of
um
and i'm so grateful when i thank god for
them um because
yeah i i
it was a rough time and i don't know if
i would have been able to escape had it
not been for
my loved ones
it was so nerve-wracking but yes we did
have an anticipated intimacy coordinator
it was such an interesting sort of
strange conversation that i never
engaged in of like
okay is it okay if he touches here is it
like every like like what can he touch
the side of your butt how about the butt
cheek are you okay with side boob are
you okay with one nipple or two nipples
things that i wouldn't have even thought
about if i was in the moment like of
just kind of going through it
me and penn had
developed a rhythm because i told him
the first day that i came on set for our
first scene i was like so dude i gotta
tell you i'm so nervous never done this
before he's like oh my god no it's gonna
be fine he's like we'll go through it
like it it ends up being like a dance if
you choreograph it all um and he's like
and just like you know talk to me like
let me know if you feel weird about
something if you're uncomfortable like
and he was just so like
helpful and like a really like i think
great person to have as an introduction
to that
in my early years of being in in the
industry and auditioning and things it
was disheartening but not surprising
that i would get a lot of auditions that
you know that on the thing it would read
open to all ethnicities um like they
they want the open casting call
and i would go to these things do my
audition whatever and when i would see
these projects come out it was always a
white girl that was in the role and
granted that could have been the thing
that you know just she happened to be
better or whatever the case what it told
me was like i don't think that you
actually wanted a different ethnicity i
think that you wanted
a white girl giving more opportunities
to people of color that they like and i
feel like even more so that now it's
it's almost like uh it's being flipped
on its head in a way now even searching
for more like projects that are filled
with people of color that redemption is
seeming isn't seeming like it's needed
to be had
i grew up a tomboy and i had a lot of
male friends growing up and still do
and i realized once i got into my teen
years that without having women around
there's a certain level of understanding
that you can't receive from speaking to
your guy best friend women have a
different sense of nurturing that i
think is really important
to always have around